going back to vomit one yeah vomit one
what now in hindsight what happened with
the release of vomit one that at the
time or even the making of it possibly
seemed a little precarious and now
you're glad that it was this way and
then in Reverse what was sort of a
mistake that you won't duplicate oh um
well what was precarious in terms of
what concerned me is when we are a
Tribeca and we had you know five
sold-out audiences you know and then we
didn't sell the film so how was the that
was the the sucky part of it obviously
and that's what you know the only reason
you're sitting here talking to me is
because that happened because if I had
sold my film and moved on to something
else you know I wouldn't you know
probably and have ended up being the
person I am now in terms of this you
know a person who's you know delved into
and thought a lot about alternative
distribution models for filmmakers you
know obviously the lack of conventional
success at tribeca when we premiered the
film you know kind of led me on this
different path which is open up a world
of opportunity to me so it's you know I
would say the main lesson is that you
know if the thing that you are hoping
for doesn't happen what might happen is
something better you know and i think
that filmmakers should you know all
artists should keep that in mind that
it's often the serendipity of life that
leads you down the more interesting
fulfilling path and so you know in a
sense it's almost thank god someone
didn't buy my film you know really
wouldn't you think about it so in terms
of mistakes that I made huh I wrote a
blog for Sundance about that like the
ten things that I would do differently
that and now I'm forgetting all of that
could probably because I men in release
mode and so I'm not thinking
about the things that I failed in and
only thinking about the good things you
know I talked about the t-shirts a lot
that I made t-shirts that were very nice
for an audience that was not my audience
so you know I should have done some
better audience research on the kinds of
t-shirts that they wanted and I made
these very nice shirts for people who
you know by women who shop in you know
Fred Segal yet because my wife was
advising me on the fabric and you know I
like those kind of shirts too to be
honest but it's not my audience doesn't
wear those kinds of shirts so that's I
mean that's a minor thing I'm trying to
think of you know because a lot of it
was at the time certain things just
weren't possible you know as they are
now so it's hard to say that I
potentially made a mistake about the way
I did things then you know because a lot
of what i did with vomit one you know i
was still operating within a certain set
of ideas and conceptions and through
releasing vomit one and also Joffrey and
working with the filmmakers that I've
worked with sins you know you know it's
a constant process of discovery but
especially you know one of the things
that I like to do and what I think that
you know in terms of my the work that I
do that I offer filmmakers is that you
know I'm constantly actually doing the
work you know and so not just making
films but releasing films and trying new
different things to see what will work
and what works and what doesn't work and
i think that that's like i use pretty
much everything i do is research you
know and so you know like doing this
contest for instance you know to help
the day the release of vomit to is kind
of a research project and then
fortunately I you know part of the
reasons I kind of put it off for a while
is because to run a contest it's very
difficult and it's very you know if you
don't have a product you like what is
the structure for that and then I just
happened to run into a guy
who had developed you know who was
working with the company that had
developed the structure for storytelling
but then we were talking about it and I
said well why don't you couldn't she
just use this also as a contest platform
and he said oh yeah I guess we could and
I said well why don't you because
they're in beta mode and I said well why
don't you just made a beta test a
contest format with vomit too and they
said great and so we're doing it will
launch you know it should be by the time
some of this runs it should be active
like it's supposed to launch may 18th
and I think we're going to do it we're
going to do three contests over the
course of three months so may 18th to
June eighteenth and the dates may change
slightly and then June eighteenth to
July eighteenth in July eighteenth
August we'll see if we end up doing
three or two we'll see what happens you
know but one of the things that you know
it's good to have long-term audience
engagement but it's also good to have
particular points of activity that have
beginnings and ends in order to mobilize
activity so while we've been keeping the
bomb at Brandel I for the last five
years and I guess one of the regrets you
know we've been keeping the brand alive
and you know we have 15,000 Facebook
Likes now which is grown from 2,000 even
just two years ago and so but now I want
to use that as well as the other the
influencers that we've kind of like been
working with or are aware of our friends
with over the last number of years to
kind of like push into this one you know
kind of promotional campaign as it were
and we're considering we're going to see
what it's like to run a crowd punk
campaign simultaneously you know and I'm
going to set the bar really low you know
partially because my audience in general
doesn't pay for things so that's one
thing you know my graffiti audience
tends to not to pay for things and
secondly I just want to see how those
things will dovetail doing the contest
in doing the crowd fund and thirdly it's
like you know we're a little in the
sense of craft
campaigns a little late in a sense
because it's right before the release so
in a sense it's more of a pre-sale than
anything else you know which I know has
been done before but as sherry has
pointed out to me you know it's like
well then what's your call to action in
the sense you know and so I'm still
figuring that out you know what that
call to action is and that's another
reason why I want to keep the bar low
because I just you know I want to do it
for engagement and participation and in
a sense you know it when I was pretty
much ready to nix the crowd fund
campaign I figured actually what's
better for my audience instead of asking
for something is like I give them
something I'm giving them an opportunity
my audience and I opportunity to engage
and show their work and participate in
this contest and then I'll showcase the
winners in a sense and but I think that
it might be good to dovetail that if you
want to contribute you can contribute in
this way or you can contribute in this
way you can either contribute some of
your work or you can contribute money
you know you you choose in a sense so
that will be interesting we'll see you
know it's going to you know I have
another week to decide
you